number one reason why we don't ask for
help is because it shows weakness you
feel like if if i ask this person for
help why would i ask for help i'm strong
i don't need your help i can do it on my
own why would i ask you a question like
this because we're worried because we're
gonna seem weak number two perfectionist
perfectionists have a hard time asking
for help because they don't think
anybody can do the job as good as they
can so they have a very hard time having
people around them that help them
because like let me just do myself you
know what i'm just gonna do this on my
own you guys can't figure this stuff out
i'm gonna do it on my own that's a
perfectionist right and if you have that
personality you're gonna build a very
small team because no one around you is
gonna be eventually learning how to do
their job because you keep doing
everyone's job yourself number three
you're afraid because if you ask and you
say hey john